Jean-Pierre Vignot est cascadeur
professionnel depuis 6 ans il a 34 ans
et cassé déjà plus de 6600
voiture un cascadeur ça n'est pas un
casscou c'est surtout un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sportif du jour on est venu au monde la
mort est avec nous on en a peur on fait
tout comme si on était éternel et rien
n'est éternel comme de toute façon
c'était le Coral dernier mot problème
que je ve que je veille pas je pars du
principe que je préfère flirter avec
elle que ça soit maomagne et puis que le
jour elle a envie de m'emmener avec elle
on est prêt on y va tranquille la tête
[Musique]
reposée j'ai pratique le karaté depuis
20 ans j'ai été champion du monde en 75
à meico cette fois champion de France et
tr FO champion d'Europe 5 ans à peu près
je fais du de la cascade autom moto j'en
suis à peu près en contelle
d'aujourd'hui à plus de 6600 voitures
passées pour la mise au
point ici la voiture de Jean-Pierre
Vigot il doit battre le record de en
longueur jamais effectué en voiture le
record à battre est de 58 m regardez
bien tout va aller très
[Musique]
vite record battu mais la réception
n'était pas prévue comme ça 64 M82 au
premier impact et 118,50 à l'immobilité
totale Jean-Pierre Vigot est blessé il
faudra plus d'une heure pour le dégager
de sa voiture mais ce Superman est
encore conscient il aura même la force
de sourire au
[Musique]